et oui c'est le moment de sortir et ce
le sera encore plus dans quelques jours
d'aller à la comédie des champs-elysées
découvrir gaspard ulliel pour ses débuts
au théâtre dans une pièce intitulée que
faire de mr claude c'est une pièce de
joe orton alors gaspard se sont vraiment
vos débuts au théâtre ça vous a manqué
ce qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
c'est une émotion supplémentaire
c'est un peu dur d'en parler j'ai pas
encore une expérience avec le public
puisqu'on est en répétition pour le
moment mais effectivement ça a commencé
dans très peu de temps mais oui je pense
que c'est une expérience totalement
différente pour l'acteur il ya une vraie
liberté en tout cas puisque à partir du
moment où on entre sur scène n'y a plus
personne pour couper comme au cinéma et
et on joue tous d'emblée vu il ya
effectivement ce rapport avec le public
il ya une énergie différente c'est
beaucoup plus stimulant mais vous
hésitiez à faire vos premiers pas dans
le temple sur une scène de théâtre c'est
toujours un peu effrayant
surtout quand on vient du cinéma comme
ça c'est quand même il ya une notion un
peu plus technique et c'est vrai que oui
j'ai été un peu effrayé et là en fait
j'ai été tout de suite rassuré par ce
projet déjà par le simple fait que ce
soit michel fau qui qu'ils soient aux
commandes la mise en scène c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé à plusieurs
reprises avec des acteurs justement qui
venait du cinéma et ça a toujours été
une réussite et voilà il a un univers
tellement particulier une folie que
j'adore et puis vous avez des
partenaires vous l'avez dit michel fau
qui fait la mise en scène et qui joue ya
aussi charlotte de turckheim alors pour
l'instant on ne sait pas grand chose sur
ce qui va se passer à la comédie des
champs-elysées vous nous avez quand même
autorisé cette semaine a rentré une
caméra avant une répétition on se plonge
dans l'ambiance dans l'atmosphère de
cette pièce anglaise
difficile de percer le mystère de la
question que faire de mr clown mais nous
avons pu pointer le bout de notre nez
avant une répétition
c'est à dire que en fait
l'idée de construire cette maison près
d'une décharge
vous montrer aussi les fûts
dégâts des eaux
mais en principe il assurant un décor
années 60 nous sommes dans la banlieue
de londres dans un misérable pavillon
dans ce pavillon une famille de dingues
un frère une soeur un grand père est un
jeune homme qui vient tout dérégler ça
parle de la folie humaine sont tous fous
ils sont tous hystérie qui sont tous à
prévisible ils sont tous eu un clash
sable sont jamais là où on les attend il
sera à la fois charmant à la fois
repoussant tous mais tout ça avec un ton
très burlesque au fait moi je dirais que
c'était hors m de pasolini revisité par
feydeau ou parle ou par le père noël est
une ordure là vous avez un petit peu
toute l'équipe technique
un fils ou un amant le jeune homme va
révéler l'envers du décor double
révélation car ce sont les débuts au
théâtre 2 c'est pareil l accessoire est
donc notre objet du désir
jour
on manipule complètement celle inverse
manille plus intimes alors gaspard vous
êtes une victime quel est votre
personnage qu'elle est quelle est sa
nature profonde c'est qu'il vient
perturber une famille mais qui est-il
c'est un ange je peux pas vraiment
répondre à cette question je ne connais
même pas la réponse moi même et c'est ça
qui est intéressant dans cette pièce
c'est que sans arrêt ya les virages à 90
degrés et c'est ce qu'a dit michel dès
le départ il faut pas essayer de jouer
avec une une psychologie de personnages
il faut répondre à une logique
d'écriture est en fait joué réplique pas
réplique c'est tellement fou et et
décousu qu'il n'y a pas d'autre manière
de l'aborder en fait les personnages
sont quasiment tous schizophrène
psychotique il ya enfin c'est
indescriptible et voilà et donc il ya
vraiment une une énergie qui sont des
gages enfin moi je suis ravie en tout
cas alors lorsque charlotte de turckheim
dit que ses théorèmes revu et corrigé
par le père noël est une ordure ou par
feydeau vous êtes d'accord avec cette
image est présent dans les médias de
tous les formes ans et grinçant c'est
noir c'est drôle c'est sulfureux un
moment les dents du thriller du pin
teurs du feydeau même du tennessee
williams est un mélange de plein de
choses et je pense qu'on a rarement vu
ça oui vous avez le trac à quelques
jours de la première gaspard bas ça
commence à pointer le bout de son nez je
suis pas de nature traqueuse mais là ça
commence un petit peu et c'est normal
c'est la première fois mais mais je
pense que une fois la première passe et
ça va très vite se transformer
en quelque chose de très agréable
comment c'est fait la rencontre avec
michel fau avec ce projet là avec cette
pièce là j'imagine qu'on vous a déjà
envoyé d'autres pièces oui j'ai choisi
celle là bas ça a été très simple j'ai
rencontré michel qui m'a contacté on a
on a déjeuné et il m'a imad fait part de
son envie de travailler avec moi et j'ai
lu cette pièce pendant l'été et c'est
vraiment ce n'était pas bon et et
c'était bien avant excusez moi bref et
en fait à la première lecture d'emblée
j'ai été séduit je me suis dit qu'il y
avait vraiment quelque chose à faire est
ce personnage était aussi très séduisant
alors ce qui manque pour l'instant vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure ce sont les
réactions du public pour l'instant vous
n'avez pas ce troisième oeil
alors comment comment est-ce qu'on
travaille comment est-ce que ça se passe
le travail en répétition pour savoir
exactement imaginer ce que pourrait être
les réactions des gens qui vont venir
vous voir
je pense qu'il faut pas essayer
d'anticiper quoi que ce soit et de
s'imaginer les réactions du public je
pense que c'est après c'est ça qui est
intéressant et qui est excitant c'est
que chaque soir c'est différent et
chaque soir on va jouer avec le public
en fonction des réactions du public en
fonction de l'humeur et de l'énergie que
va nous donner chaque public et moi
c'est ça qui m'excite cissé c'est ce
côté un peu improvisé qui peut y avoir
même si on a tous bien préparés à
l'avance il ya toujours un petit
pourcentage de de hasard qui fait que ça
rend la chose plus plus excitante est
différente à chaque fois vous aviez déjà
une expérience de la scène au cours
florent oui j'avais fait plusieurs
stages d'été mais j'ai pas une vraie
formation alors c'est vrai qu'on vous
connais beaucoup par le cinéma que des
films qui ont marqué un long dimanche de
fiançailles
hannibal
jacquou le croquant et puis vous avez
cette image aussi de de glamour d'icône
de la mode mais aussi d'un célèbre
parfum que je ne citerai pas ce soir
c'est c'est facile de gérer les deux
images vous vous posez pas la question
honnêtement je me pose plus vraiment la
question c'est vrai que après voilà le
ce tout ce rapport à la mode ce côté
iconique glamour com vous avez dit c'est
quelque chose qui est venu à moi en fait
ce n'est pas quelque chose que je
recherche particulièrement mais c'est
pas quelque chose qui me dérange non
plus et non je me sens assez bien et je
les assume totalement et en plus c'est
des belles marques avec des belles
images donc je trouve que ça va
amplifier encore plus le reste de mon
activité vous n'avez pas renoncer à
votre rêve de faire de la mise en scène
au cinéma ou pourquoi pas au théâtre
pourquoi pas je pense que ce serait très
intéressant j ai jamais pensé mais c'est
vrai que là en observant michel je me
dis que ça doit être vraiment
intéressant quels sont les rôles et
personnages vers lesquels vous aimeriez
aller les histoires que vous auriez vous
aimeriez mettre en scène aussi bon je
pense au ciné c'est très difficile
j'étais pas très comédie pendant très
longtemps même en tant que spectateurs
et c'est quelque chose qui m'attire de
plus en plus tout ce qui ce qui est du
domaine de l'absurde tout ce processus
comme y clame m'intéresse beaucoup en ce
moment on a la chance d'être dans une
ville à paris où il se passe beaucoup de
choses il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
théâtre de deux choses très différentes
de facture très différente c'est quelque
chose d'assez d'assez exceptionnel dans
une ville d'avoir tout ça sous la main a
eu les yeux plus tôt à ben on est
extrêmement chaud ce pari en termes de
musées de d'opéra de théâtre de cinéma
c'est
c'est assez exceptionnel tout à fait je
suis merci beaucoup gaspard ulliel
d'être venu nous voir ici sur le bord du
canal de l'ourcq au bord du bassin de la
villette pour ces fêtes des sorties
culturelles spectaculaire on sera avec
vous le 29 septembre au théâtre de la
comédie des champs elysées dans une
pièce de john stone que faire de mr
claude merci merci le 19/20 continue
avec catherine matausch très belle et
bonne soirée à vous
[Musique]